IS REAL.
UNFORTUNATELY IT IS REAL.
IT’S HAPPENING RIGHT NOW.
LUTHER’S ATTORNEY, WE’RE HAPPY
TO HAVE THEM ON, THANKS SO MUCH
FOR COMING ON.
SO YOUR CLIENT IS IN JAIL RIGHT
NOW?
>> THAT’S CORRECT.
HE REMANDED HER TO THE SHERIFF’S
DEPARTMENT WHILE WE WERE IN THE
COURT YESTERDAY.
>> Tucker: SO SHE WAS SUCH A
THREAT TO THE CITY OF DALLAS
THAT THERE COULDN’T BE A PERIOD
BETWEEN CONVICTION AND
SENTENCING, SHE JUST HAD TO GO
RIGHT TO JAIL?
>> THAT’S CORRECT, BECAUSE SHE
COMMITTED THE ACTUAL CRIME OF
HERESY AGAINST THE CITY OF
DALLAS AND THE OLIGARCHY THAT
DECIDED THAT REAL CRIMINALS
COULD GO TO JAIL, BUT PEOPLE WHO
WERE HERETICS -- PEOPLE WHO ARE
REAL CRIMINALS COULD BE LET OUT,
BUT THE HERETICS COULD GO TO
JAIL.
HE DEMANDED THAT SHE ADMIT SHE
WAS BEING SELFISH AND BEING
OFFENSIVE AND APOLOGIZED
EVERYBODY.
HE ACTUALLY SAID, I WANT YOU TO
APOLOGIZE FOR BEING SELFISH AND
SO, OF COURSE SHE WASN’T BEING
SELFISH, SHE WAS JUST TRYING TO
EARN A DOLLAR.
LIKE ALL OF THESE PEOPLE THAT
ARE HURTING.
SO ALL THESE SALONS COME ALL
THESE PEOPLE, THEY ONLY GET PAID
WHEN THEY DO HAIRCUTS.
THEIR CONTRACTORS, THERE’S NO
GOVERNMENT FUNDS FOR THOSE GUYS.
EVEN SHELLEY, WHO’S THE SALON
OWNER, COULD HAVE ACCESS TO SOME
FUNDS, WHICH SHE RECEIVED
RECENTLY, BUT HER BUSINESS
FAMILY HAVE NO FUNDS AND SHE
ONLY RECEIVED THAT RECENTLY.
SPEEONE SO THIS BUFFOON HACK
JUDGE, REALLY THE MOST ENTITLED
PERSON IN DALLAS -- LET ME JUST
ASK YOUR QUESTION SINCE YOU ARE
AN ATTORNEY.
SHE VIOLATED THE LAW, BUT MY
UNDERSTANDING IS LAWS ARE PASSED
BY LEGISLATURES, BY ELECTED
OFFICIALS.
THIS SO-CALLED LAW IS JUST A
DECREE?
I DON’T UNDERSTAND ABOUT THE LAW
AND HOW YOU CAN GO TO JAIL
BECAUSE HE VIOLATED IT.
>> WELL, WE HAVE A LAW THAT SAYS
THAT YOU CAN BE ENJOINED FROM
BREAKING AN ORDINANCE.
SO THEN WE HAVE A MAYOR THAT
SAYS I’M GOING TO ANNOUNCE THE
FOURTH AMENDMENT EMERGENCY
REGULATIONS AND HAVE THE FORCE
AND EFFECT OF LOSS.
THEY’RE NOT LAWS, BUT THAT’S
WHAT THEY ARE.
SO WHAT WE’VE SEEN, TUCKER, IS
THAT THIS EMERGENCY HAS EXPOSED
ALL THE TINY TYRANTS FOR WHO
THEY ARE.
THEY GOT THIS GLIMPSE OF POWER
AND MAN THEY’RE GOING TO SHOW
EVERYBODY EXACTLY WHAT TO DO.
AND SO IF YOU DON’T FOLLOW
EXACTLY WHAT THEY DO, HERE’S A
MAN THAT SAYS -- AND WE CAN
TAKE -- WE CAN SAY THAT WE
UNDERSTAND THE VIRUS IS SERIOUS
WITHOUT SAYING LOOK, WE’RE ALL
GOING TO BE WALKING DEAD ZOMBIES
NEXT MONTH, RIGHT?
WE CAN DO IS REASONABLE.
AND SO THIS MAN BELIEVES, WELL,
IT’S AN EPIDEMIC AND WE HAVE TO
DO SOMETHING, BUT HE’S
EFFECTIVE -- IF HE BELIEVES
THAT, THAN WHAT HE’S DOING IS
HE’S SAYING YOU GET A POTENTIAL
DEATH SENTENCE BECAUSE I’M
SENDING YOU TO THE JAIL THAT WE
ARE KICKING OUR CRIMINALS OUT
OF.
SERIOUS BUSINESS.
>> Tucker: HAVE A FEELING IF
SHE WAS HERE ILLEGALLY FROM
ANOTHER COUNTRY, THERE WOULD BE
ZERO THAT SHE WOULD BE IN JAIL
RIGHT NOW.
WE’RE JUST GETTING WORD THAT
LIEUTENANT GOVERNOR OF TEXAS DAN
PATRICK HAS OFFERED TO TAKE HER
PLACE IN JAIL TO PAY OR $7,000
FINE, WE DO THINK THAT WOULD BE
A SUFFICIENT OFFERING FOR MOSES
OVER THERE ON YOUR BENCH OR NOT?
>> NO, NO.
SHE HAS TO BEND THE KNEE.
THAT’S WHAT HE WANTS.
AND IN THE ORDER, EVEN IN THE
ORDER FOR CONTEMPT THAT HE SAYS,
IF YOU WILL BUT EXPRESSED
CONTRITION AND APOLOGIZE, THEN
WE COULD LOOK AT DOING THIS,
THEN WE CAN FIX THIS.
THE IDEA THAT DAN PATRICK OR
ANYBODY COULD TAKE HER PLACE IS
NOT GOING TO BE SUFFICIENT.
THEY WANT HER TO BEND THE KNEE,
NOTHING ELSE WILL SUFFICE.
>> Tucker: IS THAT ALLOWED?
I DON’T KNOW -- ARE NOT THAT
FAMILIAR WITH THE TEXAS LEGAL
CODE, BUT IS THERE A LAW IN
TEXAS THAT SAYS YOU HAVE TO
GROVEL BEFORE MORONS WERE
WEARING ROBES?
IS THAT PART OF THE LAW THERE OR
THOUGHTS OF SOMETHING HE MADE UP
FROM THE BENCH?
>> I CAN’T SAY THAT TOO MUCH,
BUT I CAN TELL YOU THAT I’VE
NEVER SEEN THAT.
I’VE NEVER SEEN IT AND I FOR
JUDGES THAT ARE MAD AT ME, BUT
I’VE NEVER HAD A JUDGE SAY YOU
MUST ADMIT HOW SELFISH ARE BEING
IN ORDER TO GRANT -- FOR ME TO
GRANT YOU MERCY.
HE DIDN’T HAVE TO DO THAT.
HE COULD’VE SAID LOOK, I KNOW
YOU’RE JUST TRY TO EARN A LIVING
BUT I’VE GOT TO ENFORCE THE LAW.
SOME GOING TO HIT YOU WITH $500
A DAY AND LET YOU GO.
HE COULD HAVE DONE THAT.
BUT THAT WASN’T WHAT HE WANTED.
HE WANTED -- HE WANTS THE
CONTRITION, HE WANTS THAT
APOLOGY.
>> Tucker: IS LIKE A POWER
DRUNK THIRD-GRADE TEACHER, CAN’T
CHEW THE GUM UNLESS YOU HAVE
ENOUGH FOR EVERYBODY, WAS THAT
PART OF HIS ORDER TOO CAN DON’T
ANSWER THAT, PURE SPECULATION.
THANK YOU FOR COMING ON-SITE AND
GOOD, GOOD LUCK TO YOUR CLIENT.
MORE THAN GOOD LUCK, WE ARE
ROOTING FOR HER.
THIS IS AN AWFUL THING THAT’S
HAPPENED AND I HOPE THAT IT
AWAKENS PEOPLE TO WHAT’S
HAPPENING A LOT OF PLACES.
>> WE FILED AN APPLICATION FOR
WRIT OF HABEAS CORPUS A FEW
MINUTES AGO WE ARE HOPING THAT
THE SUPREME COURT OF TEXAS WILL
TAKE ACTION.